welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today we are discussing music and your
brain however this episode could have
just as easily been entitled music is
your brain or your brain is music and
that's because music believe it or not
is a neurological phenomenon most of us
think of music as something that happens
outside of us the sounds we hear the
lyrics we hear their meaning how they
anchor us to pieces of our history both
emotional or social
it turns out that when we listen to
music it activates nearly every piece of
our brain moreover when we listen to
music it activates our brain in ways
that our brain itself and indeed our
body as well helped to create that music
at the level of so-called neural
ensembles that is the firing of neurons
in other words when we listen to music
our brain and our body become part of
the instrument that contributes to our
perception of that music today I'm going
to make clear how all of that happens we
will also discuss how music can be
leveraged towards shifting our brain
States and our bodily States for
instance what sorts of music to listen
to in order to make ourselves happy yes
Studies have been done on that as well
as how long to listen to music in order
to shift our mood or our overall bodily
State including how to process feelings
of sadness many of you are probably
familiar with particular songs that
anchor us to particular times in our
history or people in our history and
there's an age-old question really as to
whether or not listening to sad music
can help us process our feelings of
sadness or whether or not they drive us
further down the spiral of sadness and
despair and indeed Studies have explored
this as well so today I will explain how
music indeed how different types of
music activate different neural circuits
in your brain to create different brain
and bodily States how we can leverage
music toward things like emotional
processing shifting our emotions as well
as to enhance learning and memory and we
will also talk about the use of music to
enhance brain plasticity that is your
brain's ability to change in response to
experience not just in response to that
music but rather using music as a tool
to expand our capacity for
neuroplasticity giving us the ability to
learn far more in other contexts and
areas of life I confess that in
researching this episode I found myself
continually delighted as to first of all
how impressive the science of the study
of Music in the brain is and secondly
how fundamental music is to all of our
lives and this is true whether or not
you're somebody who listens to music
often or you're somebody that really for
silence indeed we will talk about
whether or not it's better to listen to
music or remain in silence when you
perform certain kinds of work it turns
out that there's a very clear answer to
that if you want a little bit of a Hint
it is best to listen to music in between
bouts of work or during brief rest
periods as opposed to listening to music
while you work and for those of you that
listen to music while you work and
thoroughly enjoy listening to music
while you work we will also discuss what
that means about your brain in
particular because it's likely that it
got wired up that way at a particular
phase of development and each and all of
you can learn today how to best leverage
music toward productivity but perhaps
equally important how to leverage music
for enrichment and enjoyment of life I'm
pleased to announce that we will be
hosting three live events in Australia
all three events will cover science and
science related tools for mental health
physical health and performance there
will also be a Live question and answer
session the first live event will take
place on February 10th in Melbourne at
the plenary theater
the second live event will take place on
February 17th in Sydney at the Sydney
Opera House and the third event will
take place on February 23rd in Brisbane
at the Great Hall to access tickets to
any of these events simply go to
hubermanlab.com tour and use the code
huberman I hope to see you there and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
eight sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity
spoken many times before on this podcast
about the fact that sleep that is
getting enough quality sleep each night
is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance one of
the key things to getting a great
night's sleep is to make sure that your
body temperature drops by about one to
three degrees at the beginning of the
night indeed that is how your body falls
and stays deeply asleep as well in order
to wake up in the morning feeling
refreshed your bodily temperature needs
to increase by about one to three
degrees eight Sleep mattress covers make
it extremely easy to control the
temperature of your sleeping environment
allowing you to fall and stay deeply
asleep throughout the night and to wake
up feeling refreshed I started sleeping
on an eight-sleep mattress cover well
over two years ago and it has completely
transformed my sleep it's allowed me to
fall asleep more quickly it's allowed me
to sleep more deeply throughout the
night and if I happen to wake up during
the middle of the night something that's
perfectly normal to do once or even
twice I fall back asleep far more
quickly and I wake up feeling refreshed
as a consequence my mood focus and
alertness throughout the day is greatly
elevated as compared to prior to
sleeping on my eight Sleep mattress
cover if you'd like to try an
eight-sleep mattress cover you can go to
atesleep.com huberman to save 150 off
their pod 3 cover each sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's eightsleep.com huberman today's
episode is also brought To Us by Roca
Roca makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are the absolute highest quality
I've spent a lifetime working on the
biology the visual system and I can tell
you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
challenges in order for you to be able
to see clearly in different environments
Roka understands the biology of the
visual system and has designed their
eyeglasses and sunglasses so that you
always see with Crystal Clarity
originally their glasses were designed
for performance that is for running and
cycling and for sport and indeed they
can still be used for performance they
won't slip off your face if you get
sweaty they're extremely lightweight but
I should mention that Roca eyeglasses
and sunglasses come in some of the
Aesthetics more typically associated
with performance glasses like those
cyborg Style I have glasses but they
also have a number of styles that you
would be perfectly comfortable wearing
out to dinner or to work I wear readers
at night or when I drive and I wear
sunglasses during the day if I happen to
be driving into bright light or outside
and it's just overwhelmingly bright I do
not wear sunglasses when I do my morning
sunlight viewing to set my circadian
rhythm and I suggest that you do the
same if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
Roka roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's Roca roka.com and enter the
code huberman at checkout okay let's
talk about music and your brain and to
start off I just want to take a step
back and acknowledge something that is
absolutely remarkable about music which
is
if you think about language
I could describe to you a glass I could
describe to you an apple I could
describe to you a story I could describe
to you a face I could describe to you
any number of different things and you
could do the same for me language is
essentially infinite in the number of
things that it can explain and the ways
that it can explain it
and yet if you think about music music
provided there are no lyrics in that
music can't explain how a glass is
shaped it can't even tell you that
there's a glass present in the room or
on a table it can't tell you what a face
looks like it can't tell you what that
person who owns that face did or is
doing so in some ways you might think
wow music is fairly diminished in terms
of its qualitative depth compared to
language
and yet if you take a step back and
think about what music can do it's
astonishing and it actually overwhelms
What language can do what can music do
well even in the absence of any lyrics
any words put to music music can
describe an emotion in fact music can
describe numerous types of emotions and
they can do it with a lot of nuance so
not just displaying for us happy or sad
but rather different degrees of
Happiness different degrees of Sadness
music can be used to convey a sense of
longing a sense of nostalgia a sense of
delight a sense of awe and on and on so
whereas music can't describe nouns very
well it can beautifully describe
emotions
and not only can music describe emotions
with a tremendous degree of nuance music
can evoke emotions with a tremendous
degree of nuance
now this is spectacular and it's not
only spectacular it is important because
as we move through today's episode
you'll soon come to realize that it's
very likely
and indeed we have a lot of scientific
evidence to support the fact that music
evolved prior to spoken language
moreover it's very likely that singing
evolved prior to spoken language and
that music singing and dance together
evolved prior to language making music
as well as singing and dance but really
just music even on its own in the
absence of any lyrics or any bodily
movement as the fundamental form of
human communication indeed music can
evoke empathy again we're talking about
music in the absence of any lyrics When
I Say music can evoke empathy I'm not
talking about the sort of empathy where
you look at somebody and Nod and
understand so-called cognitive empathy
which is important by the way in
relational Dynamics or emotional empathy
where you're actually feeling what the
other person is feeling but of course
you never really know what somebody else
is feeling how could you you can only
have a sense of what they might be
feeling
and you have a sense of what you're
feeling but let's be honest um as one of
our prior guests on the huberman Lab
podcast Dr Carl dyseroff so aptly noted
rarely do we ever understand how anyone
else truly feels because indeed rarely
do we ever understand how we ourselves
truly feel and certainly with language
it's very hard to explain our feelings
with words in a way that can convey the
way that we feel with the kind of nuance
that represents our own reality even in
a state of extreme happiness or extreme
sadness words fall short of explaining
how we feel inside and yet as I
mentioned earlier music not only can
describe emotions it can evoke emotions
within us and in doing so it can evoke
emotions that give us a sense of empathy
for the person playing the music or
simply for others in the world and music
can do that so powerfully because not
only does music come in through our ears
and we'll talk about the process of how
sound is converted into what we perceive
as music in a little bit because indeed
it comes in through our ears and we can
hear that music of course but the nerve
cells the neurons in your brain as well
as the nerve cells in your body
can become activated by music in a way
that the firing of those neurons
literally the frequency of those neural
impulses comes to match the frequency of
the sounds that you're hearing in your
outside environment in other words when
you listen to music not only is that
music coming into your body through your
sense organs your your hearing but your
body itself is an instrument playing
that music from within so for instance
if you listen to a piece of music that
has a lightness to it that evokes a
sense in you of the Turning of the
seasons from Winter to Spring and
something that's common in certain
classical music but other forms of music
as well
when you hear that music indeed it's
coming in through your ears but also the
firing of the neurons in your brain and
body responding to those particular
frequencies of sound is such that your
body itself is an instrument playing
that sense of the Turning of the seasons
from Winter to Spring within you which
is why your body starts to feel lifted
in some cases or it starts to feel a
lightness in some cases and an entire
set of emotions starts to be recruited
that at least for you resemble the
Turning of the seasons from Winter to
spring now that may sound rather complex
but we're going to break that process
down into its component parts but what I
essentially just said is that when you
listen to music not only are you hearing
that music but your body that is your
neurons and indeed your hormones as well
things like oxytocin and some other
hormones in your brain and body that
we'll discuss are contributing to a
symphony of emotion from within your
body and brain okay so while music can't
explain objects it can't describe them
it can explain in a very nuanced ways
emotions and it can evoke emotions
within us now if that's not amazing
enough music can not only describe and
evoke emotions it can also imply intent
think for instance about drumming that
you would hear off in the distance and
we're not talking about
we're talking drumming of this sort
and perhaps the Cadence of that drumming
changes such that as it's approaching it
gets more and more frequent
what is the intent being implied well we
know from numerous studies and you know
from numerous movies that you've seen
and heard that that sort of low
frequency drumming of increasing Cadence
as it approaches is implying the intent
of aggression or War
or at least is implying that something
serious is going to happen now contrast
that with a different frequency of sound
played at a higher case done
now
the second set of tones
are far less clear in terms of what they
mean what their intent is but if we
contrast them with let's just call them
what they're typically called the war
drums or the drums that that convey a
sense of aggressive intent
what we create then is a juxtaposition
of two different emotional states in you
perhaps or maybe you don't respond to
those with any robust emotional shift
but we are conveying two separate or
distinct sets of intent
now of course spoken language can convey
intent I could say for instance you know
I'm going to help you how can I help you
today or I could say I'm gonna hurt you
right of course with spoken language you
could do that and you could change the
intonation of that language you change
the frequency so if I were to say I'm
going to hurt you it's very different
than if I say I'm gonna hurt you okay or
if I put it as a question I'm gonna hurt
you okay so with language of course
there's also the opportunity for a lot
of nuance depending on where the
inflections where the accents are on a
particular phrase even a particular word
but with music as you recall
when we convey a sense of intent we are
also conveying that sense of intent
through the body of The Listener not
just bringing it in through their ears
and so when we do that what we do is we
start to recruit a huge number of neural
circuits that are involved not just in
understanding or a sense of empathy for
an emotion but rather that can recruit
movement or what we call pre-motor
circuits in the body pre-motor circuits
are the neurons that start to fire
before a particular pattern of action is
generated and so when we hear music that
conveys emotion that evokes emotion and
especially when we hear music that
conveys a sense of intent from the
outside we too start to feel as if we
need to move or respond to that music in
a particular way now what I just
described to you is not something that's
learned in fact it is innate how do we
know that well there are some beautiful
studies that have explored how babies
respond to music indeed how babies
respond to specific types of music
specific frequencies of sound spacing
between particular notes and on and on
it's been demonstrated for instance that
babies as young as three months old
respond to music very differently than
they respond to just other forms of
sound scrambled in time now of course
babies that are three months old aren't
speaking so you could ask them does that
sound like music how does it make you
feel Etc they're not going to answer at
least not with any coherence because
they don't have spoken language yet but
despite their absence of language we
know that babies as young as three
months old respond to music because they
do so with rhythmic movements of their
bodily Limbs and actually their torso as
well now a little bit later we will
touch on this issue of what types of
music evoke movement of the Torso versus
movement of the limbs versus movement of
the Torso and limbs no I'm not going to
dance for you during this podcast
however there's a really interesting
story there that relates to how
primitive or evolved the motor neurons
the neurons that actually move the
musculature are and how primitive or
evolved the music that one listens to is
but just to give you a sense of where
that's headed
in this study where they examined the
responses of very young babies to music
what they found is that certain
frequencies of sound evoked movements in
those babies that were rhythmic where it
was mostly their torso moving back and
forth and maybe their head a little bit
whereas other patterns of sound
different frequencies in different
Arrangements
evoked movement of their limbs more than
their torso and still other patterns of
sounds evoked movement of their torso
Limbs and head in other words babies
dancing and if you've ever been to a
wedding or a party or been out dancing
you will see people who include more
torso versus limb versus limb and torso
movement when they dance and yes of
course some of this relates to
Proficiency in dancing Comfort on the
Dance Floor
Etc but there are some Universal rules
out there about how certain frequencies
and patterns of sound AKA music
evokes different types of bodily
movements so starting from a very young
age prior to any instruction in terms of
how to dance
or what music is babies are dancing to
music and that highlights an important
point that we will return to again and
again throughout today's episode which
is that the systems of the brain that
respond specifically to movement not
just sound but specifically to musical
sounds are intimately tied to the neural
circuits of the body that generate
movement and this is especially
important to understand when we get into
our discussion about music and our sense
of motivation okay so the list of
incredible things that music can evoke
within us by way of how it activates our
nervous system and body is starting to
grow we've talked about how music can
convey emotion how music can evoke
emotion and how music can convey a sense
of intent as well now as how music can
generate action within us this is a
pretty spectacular list if you think
about it
in addition
music causes changes within our bodily
physiology that extends beyond the
nervous system although it has a
relationship to the nervous system
in particular there's been a lot of
studies that have explored how music
changes things like our blood pressure
or how fast our heart is beating our
so-called resting heart rate
and here we've made some important
discoveries in recent years and when I
say we I don't mean my laboratory I mean
Laboratories that focus on the
relationship between music and our
bodily physiology because we've long
known that music can change various
Health metrics there are some really
nice studies and I'll link to one or two
of the meta-analyzes of these studies in
the show note captions that have showed
that if people listen to anywhere from
10 to 30 minutes of Music per day and by
the way the selection of Music in these
studies ranged everything from Rock and
Roll to classical music to country music
typically these studies would ask
subjects what their favorite music is
and then they would have them listen to
that particular genre of music for
anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes per day
and if you look at the meta-analyzes of
those studies what you find is that
almost all of them see some sort of
significant effect that is some
statistically significant shift in the
bodily physiology of people that
deliberately listen to music for 10 to
30 minutes per day
not while doing anything else but just
listening to that music they find for
instance that their resting heart rate
is reduced if not during the period in
which you're listening to the music then
after the time in which they're
listening to the music they find that
their so-called heart rate variability
tends to increase for those of you that
aren't familiar with heart rate
variability having increased heart rate
variability is a good thing and that's
because heart rate variability reflects
the sort of push and pull or the balance
rather of the activation of a so-called
sympathetic nervous system which is the
one sometimes called the fight or flight
system although I don't really like that
nomenclature the sympathetic nervous
system by the way is not about emotional
sympathy it's what drives your heart
rate higher it tends to put us into
activated states where we favor movement
and motion and makes us alert whereas
the parasympathetic aspect of our
nervous system is the portion of our
autonomic nervous system sometimes
called the rest and digest system the
parasympathetic nervous system Drive
states of deeper relaxation of calm in
any event heart rate variability
reflects a periodic breaking a slowing
down of heart rate and breathing and
other aspects of our neural system
function that
Works alongside with sympathetic
activation think of sympathetic
activation as an accelerator
parasympathetic activation is a break
and when heart rate variability is
higher it reflects the fact that our
parasympathetic nervous system is
periodically engaging it's getting
activated and slowing our heart rate
slowing our breathing down music seems
to have the effect of activating that
parasympathetic aspect of our nervous
system and so we are pumping the break
every once in a while slowing down our
heart rate slowing down our breathing in
other words when people listen to music
for a dedicated period of time each day
of about 10 to 30 minutes some studies
looked at as much as 60 minutes but
typically 10 to 30 minutes what one
finds is that heart rate variability
increases not just during the period
when they're listening to the music this
is very important but also heart rate
variabilities increased Around the Clock
in those subjects even during sleep
making listening to 10 to 30 minutes of
your favorite music each day not just
what I would think to be a enjoyable
protocol if you could even call it a
protocol it's so enjoyable to listen to
your favorite music that it feels almost
inappropriate to call it a protocol
because protocol sounds kind of rigid
like you're imposing that on yourself
but if you need an excuse to listen to
your favorite music for 10 to 30 maybe
60 minutes per day and just attending to
that music not while doing anything else
which is what these studies had subjects
do well indeed that's been shown to
increase heart rate variability Around
the Clock which we know is beneficial
for your mental and physical health more
generally okay so there are dozens if
not hundreds of studies that have
explored how music impacts our
physiology and as I just mentioned it
seems that if we listen to music that we
like for 10 to 30 maybe 60 minutes a day
our physiology certain Health metrics
heart rate variability in particular
improve now in light of the positive
effects of listening to music on one's
Health there's a recent meta-analysis
that I found particularly interesting
the title of this meta-analysis is
effects of Music on the cardiovascular
system and it was published in Trends in
cardiovascular medicine now from the
title of this paper for effects of Music
on the cardiovascular system you might
think that it's just yet another
meta-analysis exploring how music
impacts heart rate variability and
things of that sort but what's
interesting about this study is that it
identifies that the way in which
listening to one's favorite music
positively impacts the cardiovascular
system and other aspects of our
physiology is very likely not through
direct changes on our heart rate simply
by listening to music but rather through
changes in our breathing and this is
true even if people were not singing
along with the music by the way now the
relationship between breathing and heart
rate is something that I've touched on
before but if you haven't heard me
discuss this I'm just going to briefly
tell you the relationship in two or
three sentences and then I'll explain
the mechanism also in about two to three
sentences so if you have a background in
biology or even if you don't this will
all be very simple and very clear
when you deliberately inhale
with a lot of vigor or you deliberately
make your inhale longer than you
naturally would so for instance if I
breathe in very vigorously through my
nose
something very specific happens to your
heart rate
it increases whereas when you
deliberately exhale
meaning when you exhale and deliberately
make that exhale longer or you
deliberately add Vigor to that exhale
or even a shorter deliberate more
vigorous exhale
you slow down your heart rate and that's
because of a phenomenon called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia which
because it includes the word arrhythmia
sounds like a bad thing but it's
actually a wonderful thing it has to do
with the relationship between a
particular muscle in your body called
the diaphragm which when you inhale our
lungs fill with air our diaphragm moves
down and our heart therefore has a
little bit more space it actually gets
bigger temporarily bigger but bigger and
when it does that whatever volume of
blood is in the Heart Is Now moving
through a larger space so it's the same
amount of blood moving through a larger
space and the nervous system registers
that as the blood moving more slowly
through that temporarily enlarged heart
and as a consequence there's a signal
sent through various Stations of the
nervous system to the heart to speed the
heart up in other words just as I said
before when we inhale our heart rate
speeds up
conversely when we exhale our lungs
empty out some air our diaphragm moves
up and as a consequence of that there's
less space for the heart and so our
heart temporarily becomes smaller and
when that happens the volume of blood
within that smaller heart moves more
quickly and that's detected by the
nervous system which then triggers a
neural signal from the parasympathetic
arm of the autonomic nervous system
which is just fancy nerd speak for a
neural signal is sent to your heart
every time you exhale to slow your heart
down so the well-established effects of
listening to your favorite music
increasing your heart rate variability
is not a direct interaction between the
sounds coming in through your ears and
changes in your heart rate while you're
listening to the music that's actually
what I would have thought happened but
this more recent meta-analysis pulls
apart the variables in these different
studies it really illustrates that when
we are listening to music We Are
subconsciously most of the times
subconsciously changing our patterns of
breathing we are inhaling in
anticipation of certain things happening
in the music we're exhaling when we feel
a relief of tension we get excited we
may get sad we may get happy we may even
just be listening to music that we don't
think is impacting our physiology at
such a core level but indeed it is music
is able to Route into our nervous system
at levels below our conscious awareness
and literally turn the various knobs if
you will of our cardiovascular system of
our breathing apparatus the diaphragm
the lungs it can evoke respiratory sinus
arrhythmia which again sounds like a
terrible thing but is actually the
reflection of a healthy nervous system
in heart and in doing so yes it
increases heart rate variability
something that is beneficial to all of
us but it's doing so by changing our
patterns of breathing so if you've ever
wondered why music can change how you
feel so robustly well it's doing that at
a deep foundational level of your
nervous system indeed at the levels of
your your nervous system that typically
are not in your conscious awareness
because I have to imagine that most of
you are probably not listening to music
and thinking oh here comes that one
chorus or here comes that one Melody and
this is where I always exhale or this is
where I always hold my breath this sort
of thing no most people are just
listening to music it's coming in
through their ears they're experiencing
some bodily Sensations maybe they're
moving their torso arms maybe arms and
torso maybe you're not moving at all no
dancing maybe just listening within your
head or maybe it's just dropped into the
background below your conscious
awareness at all and yet that music is
communicating emotion it's evoking
emotion it's communicating intent it's
activating those pre-motor circuits that
would have you move if it could and
we'll talk about dance a little bit
later but even if you're not dancing
even if you're not swaying the tiniest
bit your patterns of breathing are
changing and through respiratory sinus
arrhythmia your heart rate is changing
and through changes in your heart rate
your heart rate variability is
increasing so if ever you want wanted a
tooler protocol that was easy to use but
could positively impact your mental and
physical health well listening to your
favorite music for 10 to 30 maybe 60
minutes maybe more per day is that
protocol as many of you know I've been
taking ag-1 daily since 2012. so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast ag1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that's designed to meet
all of your foundational nutrition needs
now of course I try to get enough
servings of vitamins and minerals
through whole food sources that include
vegetables and fruits every day but
oftentimes I simply can't get enough
servings but with ag1 I'm sure to get
enough vitamins and minerals and the
probiotics that I need and it also
contains adaptogens to help buffer
stress simply put I always feel better
when I take ag1 I have more focus and
energy and I sleep better and it also
happens to taste great for all these
reasons whenever I'm asked if you could
take Just One supplement what would it
be I answer ag1 if you'd like to try ag1
go to drinkag1.com huberman to claim a
special offer they'll give you five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drinkag1.com
huberman so hopefully it's becoming
clear just how absolutely powerful music
is at evoking different physiological
responses within you that is within your
brain and body but there's an additional
one that I find particularly interesting
because it addresses and indeed answers
one of the most common questions that I
receive all the time which is how can I
get more motivated not how I Andrew can
get more motivated although of course I
ask myself that question from time to
time although admittedly most of the
time I'm wondering how I'm just going to
get everything I need to get done done
but
I often get the question how can I feel
more motivated or what can I do to
sustain my motivation over time and you
know we hear a lot of different
strategies about how to do that we hear
about the quote unquote just do it
strategy the incredible slogan that Nike
created and that persists to this day
has become commonplace in culture and
indeed the just do it form of advice can
be a good one but for a lot of people
uh just hearing just do it or telling
themselves just do it is not something
that can evoke action in them uh other
people will listen to motivational
speeches they'll look at motivational
videos they'll read motivational books
um they may even hire coaches in other
words people invest a ton of time energy
and money into trying to be more
motivated and indeed a number of
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast
have focused on the relationship between
say motivation drive and the
neuromodulator dopamine we have several
episodes about that as well as a toolkit
all of which are available zero cost at
hubermanlab.com you can access those
easily by putting motivation into the
search function at hubermanlab.com all
of that will come up time stamped Etc
but perhaps surprisingly today's
conversation about music offers us a
particularly potent tool to increase
motivation and that's because one of the
fundamental properties of listening to
music is that it evokes activation of
these pre-motor and motor circuits
within our brain and body that is the
neural circuits whose specific job is to
mobilize our body from its current
position and state to a new position in
state
so for those of you that listen to music
while you work out or prior to when you
work out you are definitely on to
something for those of you that don't
that's fine too what I'm going to
describe now are the specific sets of
neural circuits that listening to music
activates as I mentioned earlier
listening to music activates so many
circuits throughout the brain and body
that really one can take a step back
from the scientific literature on this
and say anytime someone has done a study
where human beings listen to music and
people record from a particular brain
area believe it or not even from the
olfactory system from the system and the
brain responsible for smell there seems
to be some significant shift in terms of
the neural firing there or the release
of neural chemicals
which on the one hand might lead you to
conclude that listening to music is just
sort of a non-specific generalized
activator of nervous system function
it's just kind of like turning all the
lights on but
that's not the case music in fact is
activating different neural circuits
differently in time and space to evoke a
whole set of specific reactions in your
brain and body but not the least of
which is the propensity for you to move
and this is something that you can
leverage and indeed I'll describe a
protocol by which you can leverage music
in order to greatly increase your state
of motivation okay so this is the
portion of today's episode where we're
going to discuss some specific neural
circuits but I want to assure you that
if you're a neurobiologist you can
understand this if you are not a
neurobiologist in fact if you took no
biology ever in your life I'm going to
make it clear and easy for you to
understand as I mentioned before when we
hear music it activates many many
circuits throughout the brain and body
when I say circuits I mean neurons nerve
cells that communicate with one another
sort of chains of reactions when I say
respond to one another what I mean is
when neurons are quote unquote activated
they release chemicals those chemicals
are called neurotransmitters things like
glutamate Gaba
they're also called neuromodulators
things like dopamine serotonin the names
don't really matter for sake of today's
discussion but what those things do is
they influence the likelihood that the
next neuron will be active or less
active Okay so neurons speak the
language if you will of electricity
because that's how they evoke release of
these chemicals and chemistry they vomit
out these chemicals those chemicals then
bind to little parking spots on the next
neuron called receptors and then the
next neuron gets activated electrically
and then to the next neuron and next
neuron and so on it's a chain of
electrochemical reactions okay so
there's your Neuroscience 101 lesson for
today
when people listen to music there is
heightened activation of the so-called
frontal cortex the area of your brain
which is on the surface below your skull
but just behind your forehead more or
less and that area of your brain is
involved in a lot of different things
it's involved in understanding context
you know what sorts of behaviors and
thoughts and actions are appropriate for
a given environment by the way if any of
you have ever been in an environment
where everyone was really quiet and you
thought oh my gosh what's keeping me
from just blurting out my name right now
or saying something totally
inappropriate
your frontal cortex is the one providing
the sh the so-called top-down inhibition
on that impulse to blurt something
inappropriate out and by the way your
thoughts about that impulse are
perfectly normal they actually reflect a
heightened sense of normalcy
um because it means that your brain is
thinking about how it's not going to do
that and so therefore you're not going
to do that likewise if you are ever at
the edge of a high bridge please stay on
the safe side of the railing but if you
think oh my goodness what's keeping me
from just jumping off the bridge right
now what's keeping you from doing that
is your frontal cortex it's suppressing
certain actions in a context-dependent
way in particular actions that are
dangerous to you socially physically
dangerous to others socially physically
Etc
now the frontal cortex in order to do
that also has an incredible ability to
make predictions so this is the function
of the frontal cortex that I want to
focus on for the moment your frontal
cortex is great at doing the if this
then that type of analysis if I say this
everyone will be offended or if I say
this maybe they'll laugh or if I don't
say this I'll be safe if I do say that I
won't be safe this kind of thing
frontal cortex is activated when we
listen to music because within music
there are some regularities
sometimes these are described as motifs
or melodies or choruses again this is
the entire landscape of discussion that
we could have and we will have with an
expert guest about how the mathematics
of Music impacts the electrochemical
signaling within the brain and the
coding that is the mathematics of brain
function which leads us to predict that
certain things because they just happen
are likely to happen again or not happen
again but let's set all that aside for
the moment and just State the simple
fact which is that when you listen to
music your frontal cortex increases
inactivation because it is predicting
what you're going to hear next based on
what you're currently hearing and what
you heard before now I am from the
generation that we didn't have iPods
when I was a kid we did have CDs we did
have tapes but you had to fast forward
or rewind a cassette tape or you had to
skip on the CD in order to move about
the album in time
nowadays you can queue up different
songs in different order really easily
but if you are somebody who listens to
albums start to finish or if you're like
me and you grew up listening to albums
start to finish maybe occasionally
skipping a song but
you will be very familiar with this
phenomenon which is that right is a
given song ends if you're familiar with
that album you already anticipate the
start of the next song in your head and
that just speaks to the predictive
function that the frontal cortex plays
so if you have a mixtape with a bunch of
different songs sure you don't expect
one song of a given artist to lead into
the next but if you're somebody who's
listened to that mixtape a lot so you're
familiar with What song comes next or if
you're listening to a given album start
to finish and you're very familiar with
it well then you'll immediately resonate
with what I'm saying here which is that
your frontal cortex is always
anticipating what sound is likely to
come next and this is very important
because one of the key things about
music and its ability to evoke our sense
of surprise or Delight
through the release of a neuromodulator
called dopamine we'll get to this a bit
more later is because that prediction
Machinery is thinking oh I heard that
set of chords a moment ago I'm going to
hear it again and then when it changes
up your brain goes oh whoa hold on that
wasn't what I expected and it sometimes
does that with a sense of delight like
oh yes and sometimes it hears that and
it goes oh wait what's this I don't
really like this that much I like the
opener of that song but I don't really
like the rest I think of that as um you
know there's certain pastries muffins in
particular where I really like the top
it's got the little crumbs it's got the
berries and stuff and then you like get
down past the top and then you get to
the middle then you're like oh well this
thing's not that good okay there's
certain songs like that for me so I
always thought of those as muffin songs
because the top of the muffin is always
the best whereas a donut is great the
whole way through and now I'm going on a
tangent because I'm thinking about
muffins and donuts so I'm going to take
us back to music but the point is
relevant nonetheless which is that your
frontal cortex is making predictions and
when those predictions are broken
that's a sense of novelty and when that
novelty is something that you like okay
so it evokes a sense of yes I like that
well then dopamine is deployed and when
that novelty is something you don't like
typically there's a reduction in the
amount of dopamine released in a
separate set of brain circuits below
whatever level of dopamine happened to
be there prior your so-called Baseline
level of dopamine okay so when you
listen to music there's a strong
activation of the prediction Machinery
in your brain there's also activation of
the circuits in your brain that register
novelty what are those circuits these
are things like the ventral tegmental
area and the nucleus accumbens I've
talked about these before on the podcast
again you don't need to know those names
those are the names given to certain
brain areas that control the release of
dopamine in time according to whatever
you happen to be experiencing in that
moment okay so the mesolympic reward
pathway could perhaps better be called
the mesolimic reinforcement pathway so
for those of you out there shouting wait
the mesolimic pathway does a bunch of
other things it's not just dopamine I
agree it's all serotonin it's a bunch of
other things but for today's discussion
we're thinking about the mesolimic
pathway as deploying dopamine which it
does when we hear something novel
meaning not what we predicted and we
like what we hear and then there are a
bunch of other brain centers and
circuits that listening to music
activates I'll just list off a few again
this isn't intended to confuse anybody
or add a lot of useless nomenclature but
since I am a neuroscientist and this is
a science and science informed tools
podcast I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention that we get strong activation of
a brain structure you actually have two
of them one on each side of the brain
called the amygdala this is a brain area
that's part of a larger set of circuits
that's associated with arousal okay
meaning becoming more alert becoming
more aware of our surroundings and the
particular sensory stimuli that are
coming in at particular time such as the
notes of the music or a particular set
of lyrics and music also activates areas
of the brain such as the para
hippocampal formation the cortex and the
hippocampus itself brain areas that
encode and store memories and this is
something that I think everyone will be
familiar with when you hear certain
songs or even songs that sound like
certain songs or even songs that you
swear you've never heard before it can
evoke a sense of nostalgia of longing
for something of missing somebody of
sadness or of delight and happiness and
positive memories of somebody or
something indeed I think it's fair to
say that hearing particular pieces of
music particular songs more than any
other experience can activate a whole
library of memory and emotions within us
and that's because of its ability to
activate the para hippocampal regions of
the brain the cortex and the hippocampus
itself again several different brain
areas all which communicate with one
another and other areas of the brain in
order to encode our memories
our sense of self our sense of others
our sense of history with those people
and on and on now
rather than just make this a catalog of
different brain areas that music evokes
what I'm trying to do is spell out how
music activating these different brain
areas is creating different components
of what we are familiar with as our
experience of music so frontal cortex
prediction mesolimbic reward pathway
novelty amygdala a sense of emotion and
arousal
para hippocampal cortex and cortex and
hippocampus our memories in particular
our emotional memories and our location
Memories associated with a particular
piece of music right haven't you ever
heard a song from let's say a summer
camp that you went to when you were a
kid and all of a sudden you're
remembering the smell of the grasses at
that summer camp you're remembering how
some of the kids were really great and
how some of the kids were really
obnoxious you're remembering some things
that you did remember your counselors I
mean there's just a whole landscape of
neural information there life
information stored in your head that
hearing a particular song that was sung
when you were what eight years old 10
years old I can't just flips the lid on
and it comes geysering out remarkable
now there are two other sets of brain
circuits that are activated by music
that deserve specific attention and
deserve that specific attention now in
the context of discussing motivation and
music's ability to motivate Us in
particular ways and those brain circuits
are the basal ganglia okay so this is a
set of circuits within the brain they're
associated with action initiation
so-called go circuits and withholding
action so-called no-go circuits but
basically the basal ganglia are involved
in regulating movement
and
the cerebellum the cerebellum is
sometimes referred to as the mini brain
it looks like a little mini brain in the
bottom back of the human brain
and some species the cerebellum is much
larger relative to the rest of the brain
but in humans it's like this little
piece in the back that looks like a
little mini brain like you're carrying a
second brain back there that's why I
call it mini brain cerebellum it's
involved in a lot of things but one of
its primary functions is to encode
rhythmic timing and processing and along
with its outputs to some deeper brain
stem areas things like the vestibular
and cochlear nuclei we'll talk about
this the parabrachial nucleus again you
don't need to know these names it
meaning the cerebellum along with the
basal ganglia creates patterns of
activity in our brain that Cascade down
to particular circuits in our body
so these are so-called pre-motor
circuits and motor circuits that
generate the sense that we not only can
move but that we want to move and that
we want to move in particular ways so if
you internalize nothing from the last
five minutes or so in which I've been
describing how music impacts different
neural circuits in the brain please do
take away this important point which is
that when we listen to music we think of
that as an auditory experience but now
you know that it's also an emotional
experience
and
and this is a very important and when we
listen to music it is programming a
specific set of motor actions that are
more likely to occur put differently
when we listen to music we are more
likely to move our body and not just
dance not just move our torso our limbs
or our Limbs and torso together in
concert with the music but rather move
our body from its current position to
another position and this is one of the
most important things to understand
about music music despite being an
auditory stimulus coming in through our
ears evokes the activation of neural
circuits in our brain that creates a
sort of inertia it creates a propensity
for Action across our entire body so now
that you understand that listening to
music activates lots of different brain
circuits of course the circuits that
respond to auditory stimuli so-called
primary auditory cortex is powerfully
activated by listening to music but also
circuits associated with novelty
anticipation we talked about circuits in
the brain associated with memory but
also circuits in the brain that are
associated with generating movement and
not just movement that is in sync with
or corresponds to the music that we're
listening to but all forms of movement
but when we listen to music that has a
relatively fast Cadence and we can
actually Define what that Cadence needs
to be and we'll do that in a moment
when we do that so-called pre-motor
circuitry the circuitry that's going to
initiate that kind of inertia where that
pressure for movement within the neural
circuits that actually evoke movement
are all activated so for those of you
that like to listen to music while you
exercise you're familiar with the fact
that listening to great songs with a
great beat with particular lyrics or
that associate you with a particular
time or place in your life can be very
motivating but there are data showing
that when people listen to music that's
faster than about 140 to 150 beats per
minute that it creates a heightened
state of motivation in the body to move
and the way that it does that is by way
of Shifting the balance between those
ghost circuits and no go circuits of the
basal ganglia there's some other ways
that it does it as well for instance
music can evoke the release of certain
neurochemicals called the catecholamines
these include dopamine but also
norepinephrine and epinephrine from
centers in the brain and body glands in
the body like the adrenal gland that
shift the body toward a predic position
of being more likely to move so if we
want to distill all this out to a simple
actionable takeaway
simply know this listening to music
relatively faster music predisposes you
to be more motivated to move and that is
independent this is what I find so cool
it's independent of whether or not
you're familiar with the song
independent of whether or not the lyrics
of the song are motivating lyrics if
they are that's just going to layer on
top of the faster Cadence which is going
to predispose you to move but what's
remarkable is that just listening to
that faster Cadence Music is creating a
neuronal resonance if you will a pattern
of neuronal firing within you that is
going to essentially take your and here
I'm using metaphor is going to put your
state of motivation from either back on
your heels to being flat-footed or let's
say you're mildly motivated so I'll call
that flat-footed to being forward Center
of mass so for any of you that are
suffering from lack of motivation in
particular to exercise but believe it or
not also to do cognitive work where
you're going to be still and you're
going to sit down and you're going to
read or learn or practice something
listening to music for 10 to 15 minutes
prior to doing that work prior to doing
that exercise is one of the best ways to
get motivated in order to engage in that
work or engage in that exercise that's
been demonstrated in the data very
conclusively using a variety of
different types of music and again there
are multiple mechanisms that converge to
create that heightened state of
motivation some of those mechanisms are
neurochemical like the release of the
so-called catecholamine dopamine
norepinephrine and epinephrine some of
them are strictly neural circuit based
so activation of premotor circuitry and
those are going to combine with neural
circuits that are going to narrow your
field of vision this is a good thing
whenever you want to be motivated
they're going to literally constrict
your field of vision to more of a tunnel
type of vision as opposed to more
panoramic vision and that I described it
as placing you into a forward Center of
mass I don't necessarily mean literally
a forward Center of mass
unless perhaps you're exercising like
running leaning slightly forward what
I'm talking about is using music as a
way to deliberately shift your state of
mind and body from one that is a
motivated not motivated to more
motivated and it's a very simple
protocol extracted from the
peer-reviewed literature you simply find
some faster music hopefully music that
you like it would be even better if it
was music that had lyrics that you find
motivating and listening to that for 10
to 15 minutes prior to engaging in
whatever that work may be physical or
cognitive on the topic of cognitive work
one of the most common questions I get
is what sorts of sounds or music should
I listen to in order to increase my
state of productivity motivation
concentration Etc on previous podcasts
related to focus and motivation I
touched on the use of so-called binaural
beats which are different frequencies of
Beats presented to one or the other ear
this is best accomplished with
headphones and there are a lot of
different frequencies of binaural beats
that you can get out there
um if you want to get detailed about
this binaural beats also involve the
differential between the frequency of
Beats between the two presented to the
two ears and then that difference then
is heard by higher order processing
centers in the brain in any event we
don't have to get too technical about it
we can simply say that yes there are
some decent peer-reviewed studies
demonstrating that when people listen to
so-called 40 Hertz it's a particular
frequency of sound 40 Hertz binaural
beats that it can enhance concentration
and focus however this is important
there are some recent studies that show
that binaural beats sometimes can impede
concentration and focus and thereby can
impede cognitive performance on various
tasks however the studies that show that
binaural beats can be detrimental to
performance on various cognitive tasks
did not use 40 Hertz binaural beats
specifically so we are still awaiting
more studies on binaural beats meanwhile
I'll just restate what I said before is
that there is some evidence that
listening to 40 Hertz binaural beats can
enhance concentration and focus there
are also data showing that other
frequencies of binaural beats might be
detrimental to concentration and
cognitive performance and previously
I've also discussed studies showing that
for instance if people listen to White
Noise in the background you could do
this on your computer or speakers in the
room or headphones or so-called Brown
noise which is essentially like white
noise all frequencies of sound or most
frequency of sound combined but with
particular frequencies of sounds that
are accentuated and others are notched
out as it's called so-called Brown noise
rather than understand all of this at a
technical level because I've covered
that before in previous podcasts suffice
to say if you go to YouTube and you just
put in White Noise background for
cognitive Focus or brown noise
background for cognitive Focus you can
just try those if you like during a
session in which you're trying to read
or learn or do mathematics or music or
any kind of cognitive work
if you don't like them if they don't
work for you then
um you know there's certainly no
obligation to use them likewise with 40
Hertz binaural beats and for binaural
beats you can also find those as zero
cost YouTube scripts there are a number
of zero cost apps that will allow you to
listen to binaural beats I've used the
app brainwave for some period of time
now to be honest I've never done this
strict control experiment on myself of
listening to the 40 Hertz binaural beats
or not listening to 40 Hertz binaural
beats doing the equivalent types of
tasks I can be fairly regimented with my
work and behavior but I haven't run a
detailed controlled study on myself
around this rather if I want to heighten
my level of focus or rule out
distractions what I will do is I will
listen to either white noise or brown
noise while I'll do work or I will
listen to 40 Hertz binaural beats while
I do certain types of work or sometimes
frankly I just work in silence other
times I will listen to classical music
in the background I'm a big fan of
listening to classical piano I
particularly like Glenn Gould the bach
very those are very pleasant to me but
and this is really important in
researching this episode about music in
the brain what I discovered was in the
controlled studies that have been
carried out as to whether or not people
perform better on cognitive tasks that
require a lot of focus especially
learning tasks that compared silence in
the background to purely instrumental
music in the background to music with
lyrics in the background to one's
favorite music with or without lyrics
the data are very clear it's very clear
that most people that means
statistically on average people perform
best on cognitive tasks or tasks that
require a lot of focus to perform
again these are mental tasks not
physical tasks when they are doing those
tasks in complete silence so that was
somewhat surprising to me
second best conditions are to do those
tasks in the presence of instrumental
music only and in that case there was a
lot of variation as to whether or not
people referred faster Cadence Music so
140 to 150 beats per minute or faster or
slower music 60 beats per minute or
slower I'll get back to those specific
numbers later because they represent
thresholds for inducing different types
of emotional states either happy or sad
but meanwhile
it's very clear when people work in
silence they perform better than when
they work with music instrumentals in
the background and they perform even
less well when they listen to music with
lyrics in the background we'll talk
about why that is the case in a moment
and then people perform especially
poorly relative to their performance in
silence or any of the other conditions I
mentioned when they listen to their
favorite music while doing cognitive
work and that to me was a bit surprising
especially since I spent a lot of my
University years studying while
listening to my favorite music in
different forms I'd listen to slower
music then faster music and go back and
forth and then sometimes turn it off
altogether and work in silence but the
center of mass of the literature around
this issue of whether or not to listen
to music while one studies or tries to
learn something the data are pretty
clear the data show that it's best to
study and learn either in silence or
with quiet instrumentals in the
background now I mentioned before that
previous studies compared the effects of
working in silence versus working with
40 Hertz binaural beats or white noise
or brown noise in the background and in
those studies it was found that the
white noise Brown noise and 40 Hertz
binaural beats background produced
better levels of focus I should say
heightened levels of focus and cognitive
performance and learning then working in
silence
but I've not yet seen a study that
compared 40 Hertz binaural beats
Brown Noise White Noise to music
directly and perhaps there's one out
there if there is please send it to me
I'd be very curious to learn what the
results of those are now that might seem
like a lot of information but the
takeaways from it are very clear and
it's always nice when things are clear
right
it's clear that if we want to focus and
learn that working in silence or with
white noise or brown noise or 40 Hertz
binaural beats is going to be preferable
to working while listening to music but
if you're going to listen to music while
you work that is do cognitive work then
you're going to want to listen to music
that is purely instrumental and ideally
the music would be somewhat faster than
140 to 150 beats per minute now I do not
expect you to go and measure the
frequency of beats per minute in the
music that you listen to and of course
the beats per minute are going to change
right that's an average 140 to 150 beats
per minute
I don't expect you to get super
technical break down the music that
you're listening to that is not my goal
nor is that really what this podcast is
about I think occasionally people think
that you know the the goal of a science
and science-based protocols podcast is
to optimize everything in fact I not
such a fan of the word optimize because
optimal really depends on the situation
that you happen to be in the point here
is simply this that many people out
there including myself have been
listening to some of our favorite music
while working but it's very clear as to
why that degrades cognitive performance
we know for instance that when we read
we are creating a semantic narrative in
our own head and when we listen to music
with lyrics especially music with lyrics
that we recognize the semantic content
of the song the lyrics
competes with our comprehension of the
narrative within our head from the
material that we're supposed to be
learning so now it should be sort of
obvious why listening to your favorite
music that includes lyrics while trying
to learn something else is going to
impede learning it's because you've got
multiple scripts multiple dialogues
happening in your head and in fact this
is an opportunity for me to take a
slight tangent but a relevant one which
is to say a lot of times people will ask
me how I can retain a lot of information
I confess I never use a teleprompter for
podcasting I do have a usually a short
stack of notes you know anywhere from
one to you know six or seven pages of
just
um bullet pointed notes that cue up
things that I want to talk about and
that I have researched in the literature
and then of course I'll refer to papers
from time to time but one of the things
that's been very useful for me which was
taught to me by the way by a professor
when I was in university to read and
retain information that I've read by
memory is that when I read I'm trying to
listen to the words being spoken in my
head typically my own voice although
sometimes in someone else's voice
doesn't really matter I find so when I'm
reading yes it's a process of visual
scanning but I'm also listening to the
words within my head as if they're being
spoken some of you may be familiar with
this because you do it others of you
perhaps might find this a bit more
foreign I'd be curious to know what your
process of reading and retaining that
information is whether or not it
includes an internal dialogue but
nonetheless
it should be very straightforward now to
see why if you're listening to words
that you're reading on a page maybe even
mumbling them you know a little bit
moving your lips a little bit while you
read which by the way if you heard our
episode on language and auditory
processing with Dr Eddie Chang who's
chair of neurosurgery at UCSF he talked
about the fact that when we read
any material that the brain is
generating pre-motor activity you now
know what pre-motor activity is
pre-motor activity down to the muscles
of the throat larynx pharynx
which would speak those words were those
signals to get above a certain level but
that when we read typically the signals
that are getting sent through those
pre-motor circuits are just below the
threshold of what would have us actually
speak those words put simply when we
read we are just shy of saying what we
are reading and so when I say that when
I read I'm listening to the words in my
head that's what I'm referring to so
we're starting to funnel in on some
general principles of music and how it
impacts the brain and how that can be
leveraged toward Better Learning and
better motivation both in the context of
physical and cognitive Endeavors okay so
if you want to get motivated listening
to music prior to doing something that
you're trying to motivate to do
is a good idea that's what the data say
if you're trying to learn something
that's cognitive then requires reading
focus and concentration silence 40 Hertz
binaural beats white noise or brown
noise is probably best and if you are
going to listen to music listening to
music
that includes instrumentals but not
lyrics would be best and listening to
music that includes lyrics that you're
very familiar with would be the worst
condition now with that said there are
nice studies and by the way I'm going to
link to a number of reviews and primary
studies in the show note captions that
refer back to this point I'm about to
tell you which is that listening to
music while trying to do cognitive tasks
can be detrimental toward learning that
material
turns out that if you listen to music in
the breaks between trying to learn
certain material you can actually
heighten your level of cognition and
focus and your ability to learn so I
find this particularly cool it's not
that music is bad for focus and
cognition and learning it's that
listening to music especially music that
you're familiar with that includes
lyrics at the same time as trying to
learn something else is not a good idea
but listening to music with lyrics
especially music with lyrics that you're
familiar with that you find particularly
uplifting and motivating is a cognitive
and performance enhancer when you go
back to doing that work in silence or
perhaps while listening to White Noise
Brown noise or 40 Hertz binaural beats
so like so many things the answer is not
black and white it's not that silence is
better than music or that music is bad
for learning it turns out that listening
to music even music with lyrics you're
very familiar with can be highly
beneficial for learning but that you
want to listen to that music in the
breaks be between these bouts of
cognitive work now I've done previous
podcasts that talk about how long about
of cognitive work can or should be
typically 90 minutes is going to be the
upper limit before you take a break some
people can't work for 90 minutes without
a break
by the way folks when I say without a
break I don't mean remaining in a deep
trench of focus for 90 minutes nobody
does that actually I suppose there are a
few folks that with neurochemical
Assistance or just by way of training
can get themselves into a deep deep
trench of focus for 90 minutes or more
but most people are going to focus on
something and then have their attention
flit out of focus and then they're going
to have to draw their focus back to
whatever it is they're doing that's not
just typical that's absolutely normal
and you shouldn't be concerned at all if
you try and focus for three minutes and
find your attention jumping around two
or three times during
that attempt but if you're somebody who
is going to do say a 90 minute or even
60 Minute or even 30 minute bout of work
and you are going to get up for a moment
and use the restroom or you're going to
take a break in between bouts of work so
maybe you work for 30 minutes take 10
minutes or five minutes off or 90
minutes take 30 minutes off listening to
music in those breaks
it seems can increase our ability to
focus and to learn new material once we
return to those bouts of cognitive Focus
now when it comes to physical exertion
cardiovascular exercise resistance
training of any kind many people
including myself like to listen to music
while performing
that physical exercise or that physical
exertion the data on whether or not
music improve physical performance is a
bit mixed
certainly you can find studies that show
that it improves physical output other
studies will say that it doesn't make a
difference other studies will say that
it reduces
physical output however this is a very
important however the type of physical
exercise is not very well matched
between those different studies so this
is something that I believe is going to
be highly individual in accordance with
the published data I mix it up there are
times when I will head out for a run or
I will do a resistance training session
and I will listen to music usually an
album all the way through or a playlist
all the way through that's because I
don't want to be going onto my phone
very often in fact these days I use an
older separate phone that doesn't have
any text messaging or communication to
the outside world but it has music
loaded into it
or onto it that allows me to just listen
to music so that I I don't run the risk
of getting distracted texting and doing
things like that I just want to focus on
my physical exercise I should say that
phone also has audio books podcasts
things I've downloaded to it
so it's a place where I can listen to
things but not communicate with the
outside world at least while exercising
some people do very well to listen to
music literally in between and during
their sets of resistance training
throughout their entire runs
it's going to be individual you have to
figure out what's best for you however
one of the most interesting things about
the scientific literature on this shows
that if people listen to music in
particular music that tends to be faster
more upbeat typically it's going to be
in these studies rock and roll music as
opposed to classical although there are
some studies that have explored
classical and other forms of music as it
relates to exercise listening to that
music in between bouts of exertion so in
the rest between sets of resistance
training or periodically during say a
run
or about a cycling
can indeed enhance performance in a way
that at least by my read of the data
exceeds that which is observed when
people just listen to music throughout
in other words if you find it useful to
listen to music before during and after
your workouts great be my guest however
what the data say is that switching up
between silence and listening to music
and in this case it would be listening
to music that you're very familiar with
and that can evoke a sense of motivation
and desired action in you for whatever
reason the music the beat the memories
that it draws you to
Etc
well then that's going to be useful so
there really isn't one protocol for how
to get the most out of music for sake of
physical exertion but if you're
interested in playing with some of these
variables as they've been examined
within the peer-reviewed literature I
find it interesting and indeed I found
it useful to for instance do a workout
where I only listen to music in between
sets of resistance training or to listen
to music prior to going out for a run
and then oftentimes when I do that the
song will or songs will be sort of on
Loop in my head although I confess that
a lot of times nowadays I listen to
podcasts while I run or while I hike and
when I'm in the gym and I'm doing
resistance training I like to listen to
music as opposed to content that
requires that I really focus very
heavily on that content such as a
podcast such as a book I'd like to take
a quick break and acknowledge our
sponsor inside tracker inside tracker is
a personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
help you meet your health goals I'm a
big believer in getting regular blood
work done for the simple reason that
many of the facts factors that impact
your immediate and long-term Health can
only be analyzed from a quality blood
test however with a lot of blood tests
out there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health inside tracker's ultimate plan
now includes measures of both APO B and
of insulin which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit inside tracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's
insidetracker.com huberman to get 20 off
now I'd like to talk about the use of
music to shift our mood and indeed to
get us out of states of anxiety this is
a really interesting scientific
literature with some very specific
actionable takeaways that I think
everyone will find beneficial I
certainly did
however I want to point out that we
don't need a scientific study to
illustrate for us the way that music can
shift our mood and you already know why
it is that listening to a sad song can
sometimes make us feel sad listening to
happy music can make us feel happy it's
because when we listen to music there
are some fundamental components of that
music literally the mathematical
structure of that music including the
frequency of sounds the Cadence of those
sounds as well as the lyrics but even in
the absence of lyrics that are
activating brain circuits within us such
that the frequencies of sound that we're
hearing are evoking firing of neurons in
the brain of the same frequency in other
words your brain becomes a bit of a
piano playing the same
song that you're hearing inside your
head now that's sort of a duh right you
hear music in your head even if you're
listening to it from outside in the room
but when you understand that neurons
speak the language of electrochemical
communication what we're talking about
here is particular music evoking the
release of neurochemicals in your brain
at a particular frequency so just think
about that for a second we know that
neurochemicals such as dopamine
serotonin some of the so-called
endogenous opioids right these aren't
opioids that people take this isn't
related to the opioid crisis we're
talking about endogenous opioids that
are released in response to music things
like exercise different types of social
interactions those and other chemicals
are released according to the firing of
specific neurons and we know that when
you listen to music at particular
frequencies arranged in particular
motifs
Etc that the neurons that release those
neurochemicals are firing at those same
frequencies in other words that the
sound is causing a
sound-dependent pharmacologic concert
within your brain so that fact should
make it incredibly clear as to why
certain music even in the absence of
lyrics can evoke certain emotional
states certain sound frequencies are
transformed into the neural language
within your brain that releases certain
neurochemicals that create certain
emotional states of brain and body just
to drill in how incredible that really
is a little bit further
if you see a beautiful painting or the
picture or presence of somebody's face
in real life that evokes a particularly
strong positive or negative emotion
you can imagine that of course it
creates the release of certain
neurochemicals or perhaps in the case of
a negative face suppresses the release
of certain neurochemicals but we can't
say that a particular frequency of color
say Reds against oranges or the presence
of a rainbow evokes a sort of
rainbow-like cascade of neurochemicals
whereas with sound that's exactly what's
happening and this isn't to diminish the
value of vision in terms of its ability
to evoke emotional states within us
after all I'm foremost a neuroscientist
but under the umbrella of
neuroscientists I started off as and I
continue to be a vision neuroscientist
studying the visual system and its
ability to evoke emotional states within
us but I have to acknowledge that the
auditory system and in particular the
circuits in the brain that respond to
music have a remarkably potent ability
to evoke these emotional states which is
why when surveys have been done asking
people why they listen to music the
responses that have come back generally
resemble the following statistics
approximately 90 of people say they
listen to music to relax approximately
82 percent of people self-report that
they listen to music in order to make
themselves happy
approximately 46.5 percent of people say
that they listen to music in order to
process particular states of emotion
we'll get back to what process means in
a moment but more often than not when
these Studies have asked specific
questions about what particular types of
emotions people are listening to in
order to process their emotions better
it is the emotion of sadness
and 32.5 percent of people
report that they listen to music in
order to increase their sense of
concentration and we already talked
about the role of Music in concentration
or its ability in some cases to inhibit
concentration a few minutes ago now you
might be asking yourself how can 90 of
people listen to music for one thing and
82 percent of people for another thing
and so on and so forth were well over
100 of people ah well in this survey and
other surveys like it people have the
option to give multiple reasons for
listening to music because of course
most people have multiple reasons for
listening to music
now with that said if we are to examine
this one particular category nearly half
of people who report listening to music
on a regular basis listen to music in
order to process their emotions
we can ask what does the scientific
literature tell us about how certain
types of music evoke certain types of
emotions or help us process certain
emotions and we'll get back to what we
mean by process in a moment but
a number of Studies have been done on
this there's some meta-analyzes that
Converge on some general themes what I
refer to as the center of mass of data
right when there are a lot of studies in
a given area the outcomes of some of
those studies conflict with one another
generally in a good meta-analysis what
happens is different studies are
considered more powerful or less
powerful than others depending on how
many subjects were involved the
different control conditions or lack of
control conditions and so on and so
forth this is one of the great values of
meta-analyzes
is that they don't treat all studies
equally they separate it out studies
based on their level of rigor and
thoroughness well what we can say with
confidence is that
music that makes us quote unquote happy
or tends to shift People's State from
less happy to happier regardless of how
they enter the experiment tend to be
faster music meaning music that on
average contains
140 to 150 beats per minute or faster
okay and there's some other features to
quote unquote happy music if you will
that it tends to be in a major key that
if there are lyrics to that music that
the lyrics tend to report things that
are happy or get this total nonsense in
fact when the type of lyrics in this
happy music's I guess singing about
um great events in life and positive
things falling in love being in love
positive memories birth of children
connection to friends Great Adventures
those lyrics or I should say that music
containing those lyrics was no more
effective in creating states of
happiness than was music of equivalent
Cadence so again music that was 140 to
150 beats per minute or faster on
average
well even if the lyrics were complete
nonsense even if the vocalizations
weren't actual words
it still evoke the same increase in the
level of happiness in the subjects than
when compared to the music containing
coherent lyrics around happy events what
this means is that the Cadence of music
is no doubt the critical variable when
one is trying to shift one's mood from a
state of whatever could be depressed or
sad to non-depressed nonsad or neutral
to positive and so on and so forth
but what this also explains is one hit
wonders
rarely if ever by the way are one hit
wonders sad and depressing songs
sometimes almost always these one-hit
wonders are songs that are very
effective in shifting people's mood from
not so happy to happier or we could just
say happier regardless of where they
started out before listening to the song
they feel better while and after
listening to the song
and indeed more often than not the
lyrical content of those songs
is not particularly meaningful it's not
addressing a particularly meaningful
state or issue it's just what some
people call a party song or something
that's just uplifting not just to them
to but to many other people which
actually brings up an interesting and
future looking point which is that
nowadays we are seeing the emergence of
AI Artificial Intelligence being used to
generate new songs by capturing these
well-established rules gleaned from
Neuroscience of how music impacts the
brain such that in the future artificial
intelligence is going to be generating
hit songs for us as opposed to having
people generating hit songs I know this
evokes a state of concern and fear in
many people I think that um this is uh
fear that needs to be matched with
um I don't know perhaps a cautious
optimism I mean who knows maybe there
are patterns of music including lyrics
that human beings in their current
understanding of themselves and of Music
have not yet been able to tap into and
who knows maybe AI will be generating
the best music that we've ever heard or
perhaps music that can shift our States
from more depressed or sad to heightened
levels of happiness in ways that humans
have just not been able to accomplish so
I think it's important to balance any
pessimism about Ai and its ability to
generate music based on these rules of
how music impacts the brain with an
open-mindedness after all neuroscience
neuroimaging and neural recordings
directly with electrodes in the brain
while people are listening to music is
teaching us how the brain responds to
that music and is giving us information
that indeed human beings but also
computers can use in order to generate
stimuli music that can shift our brain
into more positive States and if that's
the case wouldn't that be wonderful
another established feature of happy
music is get this its ability to get
people to relax the furrow of their brow
and need to raise their eyebrows and to
be a bit wide-eyed and not just through
autonomic arousal but rather through
activation of the muscles in the face
conversely we know that sad music and
here we can Define sad music this has
actually been done in the literature sad
music tends to be slower than average
slower than 60 beats per minute or so
again on average and this again is
independent of the lyrics that might not
even be present in the song
sad music tends to activate the
corrugator muscles
of the forehead which are the muscles
that Furrow the brow and that lead to a
kind of serious look it's in an it's a
folding in of the face as opposed to a
widening up of the eyes and a relaxation
of the brow now given where we are in
the course of this discussion that
shouldn't be surprising we already
talked about how listening to particular
sounds evokes the release of particular
neurochemicals but in a more direct
fashion
listening to particular sounds activate
certain pre-motor and motor circuits
within the brain and body not just the
desire to move one's torso limbs or both
Bob one's head or move ahead side to
side but also the micro structures of
the face which because one of the main
roles of the face is to communicate
emotion
is going to cause either a relaxation of
the brow and a lifting of the eyebrows
or a furrowing or a activation of the
corrugator muscles of the eyebrow and if
that's not obvious and yet interesting
enough well get this
there seems to be a direct relationship
I'm chuckling because this still just
blows my mind because it's a total duh
obvious when you hear it but it's still
just so cool that there's a direct
relationship of the frequency of the
sound that you hear either low pitched
or high pitched and the Cadence of that
sound and here I realize I'm not using
technical music theory language but
whether or not the that particular tone
is played over and over close in time or
more spaced out in time and facial
expressions and indeed
when we listen to
bass tones low frequency tones set apart
from one another with some distance so
that they're not overlapping we get the
all too familiar
bass face so what I'm referring to here
is what neuroscientists would call a
labeled line literally a circuit of
neurons that goes from the periphery in
this case our ears into our brain
through several different stations and
then
Wicks out to impact all sorts of things
within US states of emotion states of
motivation our propensity to move but
also a labeled line circuit coming from
hearing low frequency sounds played
spaced apart from one another that
evokes a particular facial expression
and again this takes us back to the
earlier statement that I made which is
not an original statement frankly there
are people within the field
of auditory processing and understanding
how the brain processes music in fact
one of the world experts in this Dr Eric
Jarvis at the Rockefeller University was
a guest on this podcast where we talked
about the relationship between music
movement and singing and the fact that
music movement in particular dance and
singing likely preceded the evolution of
modern spoken language
well Eric Jarvis and others have argued
quite convincingly that these circuits
that I'm calling labeled lines to
particular facial expressions and states
of emotion are the most fundamental
components of communication and the ways
that humans have communicated about
their emotional state and literally
induced that same emotional state in
other members of our species dating back
tens of thousands if not more years one
of the fun things about researching this
episode on music in the brain is that
there are a lot of quality studies
exploring how music impacts the brain
neuroimaging neural recording data from
excellent Laboratories as well as a lot
of studies in fact a surprising number
of studies exploring how particular
types of music impacts mood States and
fortunately that allowed me to glean
some very specific recommendations as to
the minimum amounts of say happy music
that you need to listen to in order to
shift your mood into a happier State and
indeed the numbers exist in the
literature and it has been shown that
the threshold for significantly shifting
one's mood into a happier state by
listening to the sorts of Music we
talked about before that faster Cadence
Music even with nonsense lyrics although
it could include other lyrics instead is
nine minutes not ten not eight but nine
and I'm sort of joking when I say not
ten not eight but nine because of course
you could listen to music for 10 minutes
or 15 minutes or longer in fact earlier
we talked about the benefits of doing
that but
when one examines the various studies
that looked at how long subjects need to
listen to music in order to shift their
mood into a happier State the threshold
seems to be nine minutes so if you want
to feel happier than you currently feel
it seems that listening to happy music
for nine minutes or more is going to be
the effective approach okay so nine
minutes or more to shift one state to
happier what about to process somber or
sad feelings feelings of loss
well this raises an even bigger question
and it's a question that I also get very
often so you're noticing I get a lot of
questions often in any event
one of the common questions that I get
is when we are feeling sad
or experiencing a loss you know grieving
that the loss of a relationship by you
know by death or decision or by somebody
moving away or the loss of a pet Etc
is it better to go into that state in
other words to quote unquote feel one's
feelings or to counter those feelings
now historically that's been a very
difficult question for me to answer
because who am I to say whether or not
you should feel your feelings or whether
or not feeling those feelings will take
you down a trench of feeling much worse
or much better in fact there's an
emerging literature exactly about that
issue that is whether or not the
catharsis model is really vascotharsis
being the expression and feeling of
one's emotions as a way to extrude or
get rid of those emotions or whether or
not that simply drives us further down
the trench of those emotions that's
really something that we should address
in a separate podcast episode and I will
have experts from the fields of
Psychiatry and psychology to help us
address that question directly but
since we're talking about music in the
brain and the fact that music has a
tremendous capacity to evoke emotional
States including sad States
what has been shown in the peer-reviewed
literature is that when people who are
feeling sad for whatever reason
loss of relationship death who knows
doesn't really matter why they're
feeling sad after all
it's that they're feeling sad listening
to 13 minutes or more of sad music
that music can contain lyrics they are
familiar with or no lyrics regardless of
whether or not it contains lyrics it's
going to be on average 50 or 60 beats
per minute or less we established that
already
listening to that for 13 minutes or more
has been shown to be effective in
allowing people to quote unquote process
their somber feelings and to some extent
to move past their feelings of sadness
so
those studies support the idea that when
feeling sad feeling one's feelings and
perhaps even amplifying those feelings
of Sadness by listening to sad music for
13 minutes or more can help people
process those sad feelings and while
that point might seem overly
reductionist I actually think it's a
real value I'm certainly familiar with
feelings of loss feelings of grief and
I've often struggled with this question
of you know gosh do I try and just push
it aside or do I deal with those
feelings
again this is something that you really
need to determine for yourself but what
these studies show pretty conclusively
is that when we're feeling sad matching
that sadness or amplifying that Sadness
by listening to sad music for 13 minutes
or more can help us move through that
state of sadness and one could argue
this is more or less the use of
catharsis of amplifying emotional
expression or feeling
in order to try and move that feeling
out is a classic idea of originating in
Freudian psychology but probably before
then as well but in any event I think
these data support the idea that even
when feeling sad perhaps especially when
feeling sad
amplifying or matching those feelings
through the use of sad music for 13
minutes or more
again you don't need to set a timer for
13 minutes but giving yourself a period
of time to just listen to that music is
one way that can help you move through
that state of sadness and then be able
to lean back into other areas of life so
we've talked about the role of Music in
evoking or shifting states of happiness
and sadness
there are also interesting data that
support the use of music for shifting
one out of a state of heightened anxiety
and I find this especially interesting
because my laboratory for a long time
has worked on behavioral interventions
to reduce anxiety things like the
physiological Psy which if you're not
familiar with you can put physiological
PSI in my last name into YouTube and
there's a demonstration of that it's a
breathing technique of two inhales
through the nose and a long exhale
through the mouth the lungs empty that
at this point in time we understand to
be the fastest and most effective way to
reduce one's levels of anxiety in real
time so it's two inhales through the
nose long to lungs empty exhale through
the mouth
that's the physiological PSI
earlier we talked about the fact that
one of the main ways in which listening
to music shifts heart rate and increases
heart rate variability and thereby
positively shifts a number of different
Health metrics is through shifts in
breathing so I justify that brief
vignette about the physiological PSI as
within the general context of what we're
talking about today
in any event
there are data that have explored
whether or not specific musical stimuli
can be used to significantly reduce
anxiety in particular one published out
of the University of Pennsylvania and
I'll provide a link to the study in the
show note captions which shows that
people that listen to a particular song
that I'll describe in a moment
experience up to 65 percent reductions
in their anxiety and that's a
significant reduction in anxiety and I
should point out that
65 reduction in anxiety in this case was
accomplished with just three minutes of
listening to this one particular song
and get this that particular song was as
effective in reducing anxiety as one of
the most commonly prescribed
benzodiazepines so what is this magical
anxiety reducing song the title of the
song is weightless by Marconi Union
I hadn't heard of the song prior to
researching this episode I did indeed
look up the song on YouTube and listen
to the song I will provide a link to the
song in the show note captions I confess
that it is a very relaxing song I also
confessed that I was not experiencing
anxiety when I listened to the song but
it was successful in reducing my level
of overall autonomic arousal I found
myself more relaxed Etc now of course
what I'm describing in terms of my own
experience is not a peer-reviewed study
it's what I would call anik data meaning
I'm just describing my experience but
again there are peer-reviewed studies
exploring how this particular song
shifts one's autonomic State and I think
this three minutes of listening to this
one song should at least be Tried by
anyone that's trying to reduce their
anxiety Because unless you're listening
to the song in some way that I'm not
aware of like excessively loud or
something of that sort I can't imagine
how listening to the song would be
detrimental in any way and if you are
anything like the subjects in the study
that they explored it could very well be
beneficial and help you reduce your
anxiety it's also something that you
could keep queued up in your phone or on
any device such that if you think you
may experience anxiety you just put your
headphones in and listen to it you might
be wondering whether or not Marconi
Union's weightless is only three minutes
long well I don't know the answer to
that because when you go on YouTube what
you'll see is that clearly a number of
people are benefiting from listening to
the song to reduce their anxiety or at
least that a number of people have
listened to this song Because if you put
Marconi Union weightless into the search
function on YouTube what you'll quickly
discover is that the top video has get
this 47 million views and it's 10 hours
long now across today's episode it's
been in the back of my mind that some of
you out there perhaps are trained
musicians that you grew up playing an
instrument perhaps sang in choir or at
school perhaps you played multiple
instruments perhaps you even know music
theory whereas others such as myself
were encouraged to play an instrument
when we were younger but then abandoned
that instrument in fact I'll just tell
you a brief story when I was a kid every
kid in school was required to pick an
instrument my parents for whatever
reason clearly they didn't ask me what I
want to do they asked me to play the
violin in school and I got the violin
started playing the violin I took the
Suzuki method lessons this is where you
don't learn to read music directly you
there's a number assignment to the
different notes and that's initially how
you learn I was also supposed to listen
to the songs while I slept this idea
that some of the music and musical
learning could be encoded during sleep
an interesting topic because there's
actually some emerging evidence for that
now but at the time as far as I know
there were no peer-reviewed studies but
nonetheless it was thought that this
works and perhaps it does well I can
tell you one thing for sure it did not
work for me because I have one photo and
truly just one from a concert that I
played I must have been about eight or
nine years old and within this photo
what you'll notice is there's a gallery
of children all with violins all of
whom's bows are up
and my bow is down that in addition to
the fact that my fly was open in the
picture and the fact that every time I
played the violin either by practice or
with the teacher present when we would
go to these once a week
sessions with a individual teacher
people would cringe animals would cringe
literally dogs would howl such that my
parents
did not encourage me to continue playing
in fact they and many others encouraged
me to quit playing so I quit playing I
confess I don't know how to play any
instrument I've attempted a few other
instruments in my lifetime yes I believe
in neuroplasticity it is a Hallmark
feature of our brain our brain can learn
things even as adults but the point I've
tried to make here is that I am not of
the category of kids that played an
instrument
and understands music theory or how to
read music I simply don't and I realize
that those of you that are listening to
this or watching this out there are
probably in a mixed category of
proficiency all the way down to what I
would consider my own relationship to
music which is deficiency although I
greatly enjoy listening to music and I
do have a pretty good ability to
memorize lyrics
in any event
the reason I raise this is that there
are now dozens if not hundreds of
quality peer-reviewed studies using a
variety of technical approaches that
show that when children especially
children younger than eight
learn to play an instrument and even
better learn to play multiple
instruments
regardless of whether or not they learn
to read music that it leads to greatly
enhanced connectivity within their brain
that persists into adulthood and that it
facilitates other forms of
neuroplasticity and learning which is
basically to say that my brain very
likely does not include these enhanced
circuits which circuits am I referring
to well there are a number of different
circuits in the brain that have been
shown to expand when children learn how
to play an instrument as a child eight
or younger and again eight isn't a
strict cut off and I always have to
highlight this forgive the tangent but
when we say eight or younger I don't
want people with nine-year-old children
or a 10 year old kid or even 16 year old
kid listening or even adult listening to
think oh you know the window is shut for
me because when one designs a study you
have to have some thresholds who you
include and who you don't include and
some sometimes that leads to these kind
of artificial perceptions about where
the cutoffs are but in any event it's
very clear that if you did learn an
instrument when you were young or
ideally even multiple instruments and
even better would be to learn multiple
instruments and how to sing along with
instrumentals especially in an
improvised manner
well your brain has expanded
connectivity on average relative to
children that did not have that
experience now the good news is that
learning how to play an instrument or
even thankfully for me
listening to novel forms of music music
that you don't typically listen to for
30 to 60 minutes per day and it doesn't
have to be every day in fact it can even
be just three days a week for 30 to 60
Minutes has been shown to expand brain
connectivity in ways that of course
lends itself to better musical
comprehension and even performance but
learning how to play a musical
instrument at any age as well as singing
and singing especially with others in a
group has been shown to enhance learning
and the acquisition of new skills
separate from musical learning and
singing in other words it seems that
learning how to play an instrument and
singing are a gateway to neuroplasticity
and this is again supported by
neuroimaging data some of the more
striking of those data are that you know
children that learn how to play one to
three instruments when they were a kid
or that sang in a choir or a group or
that we're taught to sing solo for that
matter show up to 30 percent greater
connectivity within this particular
their brain Network that links the two
hemispheres of the brain now as soon as
I say two hemispheres of the brain it
starts drawing up a lot of ideas in
people's heads mainly derived from pop
psychology that you know there are
left-brained people and right brain
people
I've touched on this before but I want
to make this abundantly clear again now
most of what you've heard about
so-called left-brained People Are
right-brained People is complete and
total nonsense it's myth there are some
functions in the brain that are
lateralized to the left or the right
hemisphere in particular porosity they
start lilting and falling of speech and
in singing is highly lateralized in the
brain other aspects of language can be
lateralized in the brain but really if
you hear that certain people are more
emotional or certain people are more
logical based on right brain left brain
stuff that stuff is completely false
it's complete garbage in fact it's not
based in any real solid data so when I
say that learning an instrument or
learning how to sing young or even as an
adult is beneficial for increasing the
connectivity between the two sides of
the brain what that increased
the brain which is by the way mediated
through a structure called the corpus
callosum
is not about enhancing one's emotional
capacity or logical capacity it's really
about increasing the capacity of all
brain circuits or at least the brain
circuits that are connected up directly
with the corpus callosum which includes
many brain circuits for things like
cognition language learning speech
mathematics a lot of people don't
realize this but a lot of musicians are
also especially Adept at mathematics and
for you musicians you're probably
nodding of course right because the
music is grounded in theory that has
basis in math and in physics something
that we will address in a future episode
about harmonics Etc
when children or adults learn how to
play a musical instrument or several or
how to sing and play musical instruments
that increase connectivity in the corpus
callosum is essentially providing
multiple highways of option for learning
all sorts of things so it's something
that I highly encourage so much so that
I intend to finally finally learn how to
play an instrument I've got a particular
instrument in mind that I've wanted to
learn how to play for a very long time
but based on my prior experience with
trying to learn an instrument and
because I like to consider myself a
considerate person I intend to do this
more or less in isolation from people
and indeed from animals as well and for
those of you that don't have the time or
energy or desire to learn new forms of
Music you'll be perhaps delighted to
know that just listening to novel forms
of music and in particular when you
listen to novel forms of music and you
pay attention to that music not just
letting it play in the background that
too has been demonstrated to expand the
brain's capacity for neuroplasticity its
ability to modify itself and make it
better at learning other sorts of things
both cognitive and physical so I highly
encourage you to listen to the music you
love I certainly love to listen to the
music that I Delight in and have for so
many years but there's also strong
scientific support to encourage
listening to new forms of music that
hopefully you will like but nonetheless
the mere foraging for and listening to
novel forms of Music itself seems to
activate brain circuitry in a way that
allows for Better Learning and
comprehension of all sorts of things so
today we've been talking about music in
the brain and I confess this is an
enormous topic so much so that I had to
discard with entire sets of data and
discussion around for instance the
mathematical structure of music and how
that relates to the mathematical
structure of firing of neurons we
touched on this a little bit however in
the context of certain frequencies of
sounds that we hear creating certain
frequencies of neuronal firing and
activation in the brain I mean just
think about that how amazing that is
it's literally like the brain playing
your neurons like a piano this is not
what happens when you smell a particular
odor or taste a particular taste or see
a particular face or visual stimulus
incredible things happen within those
senses as well but there is something oh
so fundamental and incredible about
music and its ability to tap into our
neural circuitry and our neural
chemistry in ways that shift our
emotional states and our motivational
States so we talked about ways that
music can be leveraged to shift our
emotional and motivational States again
not as a way to reduce music to its
reductionist parts but rather to help us
gain understanding into how the brain
responds to music and how we can
leverage music of all kinds with and
without lyrics how we can balance the
contrast between music and silence to
increase motivation and so on and so on
for those of you that are interested in
the more formal structure of music and
how it relates to brain function and
vice versa as well as for those of you
that are interested in singing and
songwriting and more along the lines of
lyrical content and how singing in
groups and how improvisation of singing
and musical playing can impact brain
function and plasticity I promise you
there's going to be both an expert guest
coming on the podcast to discuss that as
well as a solo episode on those topics
again the topic of music and the Brain
being far too vast to cover in just one
conversation with that said I hope that
today's discussion allowed for you to
think about music differently hopefully
it will lead you to listen to music a
bit differently perhaps even leverage
music for different purposes in your
life and above all to think about music
and to enjoy music either listening to
it or playing it or both because as you
now know music isn't just able to
activate your brain but rather your
brain contains vast amounts of real
estate that are literally there to
listen to music if you're learning from
and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zero cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a five star review
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions for me or comments about
the podcast or guests that you'd like me
to consider hosting on the huberman Lab
podcast please put those in the comments
section on YouTube I do read all the
comments not on today's episode but on
many previous episodes of The huberman
Lab podcast we've discussed supplements
while supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for Focus the huberman Lab podcast has
partnered with momentous supplements
because momentous supplements are the
very highest quality they also ship
internationally and they tend to focus
on single ingredient formulations which
makes it easy to develop the most
biologically effective and
cost-effective supplement regimen for
you if you'd like to see the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so it's livemomentis.com huberman if
you're not already following me on
social media please do so I am
hubermanlab on all social media
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
LinkedIn threads and Facebook and on all
those platforms I cover science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content on the
huberman Lab podcast so again it's
huberman lab on all social media
platforms and if you haven't already
subscribed to our newsletter we have a
zero cost monthly newsletter it's called
the neural network newsletter that
provides podcast summaries as well as
tool kits such as a toolkit for Sleep
toolkit for Focus toolkit for
neuroplasticity toolkit for Fitness
deliberate cold exposure heat exposure
and on and on again all available zero
cost you simply go to hubermanlab.com go
to the menu scroll down to newsletter
tap on newsletter and then give us your
email and I want to emphasize we do not
share your email with anybody thank you
once again for joining me for today's
discussion about music and your brain
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science
[Music]